- We now live in a world
where transparency has won.
Speak the truth. Do the right thing.
Kindness is cool. Truth is cool.
Don't act like you've made it.
Talk about the journey
of trying to make it.
(uplifting music)
- For me, one of the
most interesting things
that I watch everyday in this space
is people think that fake it
till you make it is still real.
There are so many people posing it
because they feel like they
have to inflate their backstory
or what they're capable of
or the advice that they're
giving to break out.
Yet that is the exact same
reason that they won't break out.
I think too many people want
to fake it till they make it,
or project someone they're not
which is why 99% of people are losing.
It's just so crazy, all this fodder
in the system that isn't true.
All the faking it till you make it,
as a fashion brand that's elite
or at what every single
fucking 23 year old male
in the world is doing which
is fronting on Instagram
because boys want girls.
And where I see kids
getting caught all day
is they're fronting,
they're making pretend,
they're posturing, they're
faking it till you make it.
The problem with faking it till
you make it in today's world
is you're exposed.
I'll tell you what fake it till make it is
a kid rents a texuedo,
goes to his uncle's best friend's house,
rents a Lamborghini,
drives it to that house,
pays some Instagram models
to come and be in bikinis,
and then say "This is my
life and you can do this too
"if you pay me $6,000 to teach you how."
Fronting, posutring,
or, my favorite that
all of you bought into,
fake it until you make it,
look the fucking part.
Let me tell you from all the homies
that live life looking the part,
for all you fuck faces
wearing fake watches,
(audience laughs)
and a suit that you can't afford
because somebody fucking told you
that you have to look the part to win.
Let me tell you who you're
fooling with your look the part,
other fucking losers.
I think fake it till you
make it internally, you know,
trick yourself that you
got it, that's good.
I like the delusional thing.
- Yeah, positive self talk.
- Yes, Yes.
Blind faith, blind faith.
But when you start putting
that out to the world,
now you're fronting,
now you're bullshitting,
and you're losing equity with
the people that you want to,
again, I always tell people
you're tricking losers.
Like, like, you're losing too much
when you fake it till you make it
with the A-players of the universe.
Like, nobody's tricking me.
Like, I know you bought your
fans, your engagement blows.
The quickest way for me to know
somebody goes in the L column for life
is when they're faking
it until they make it.
You know, this whole
fake it till you make it
brings no value to anybody.
You need to tell me what you're gonna do
which is very scary 'cause you
actually have to execute on.
You know, listen, I
always used to say this:
"It's like doing pushups."
You and I, if we want muscles,
you have to do the pushups.
You can't read about
the doing the pushups.
You can't outsource doing the pushups.
(laughing)
And so there's a reason that people
who are authentic and
actually doing are winning
because everybody else is trying
to figure out the shortcut.
Definitely don't overthink it.
- Right.
- If you're as good of a
dude as you think you are,
it all works out.
- I am authentic to who I am.
- Me too, man.
I got shortcomings, like, like, you know,
that's all it comes down to.
As long as your shortcomings
aren't, like, real shit.
- Right.
- That's why nobody wants
to build their brand
'cause they're harassing people,
'cause they're stealing money,
because they're doing dumb shit.
- (laughs) Right.
- You certainly have no bad
in you, no bad intentions,
and you just put it all out there, yeah,
you're gonna end up somewhere good.
- It's why this is working for me.
I'm growing because the truth
is winning more and more.
We now live in a world
where transparency has won.
Speak the truth. Do the right thing.
Kindness is cool. Truth is cool.
Don't act like you've made it.
Talk about the journey
of trying to make it.
(electronic music)